bonjour jean paul stahl merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur arte france alors
le ministre de la santé elle a dit la
situation est meilleure qu il y a
quelques jours encore à quelle est la
situation exactement chez vous au chu de
grenoble
malik est toujours un décalage entre ce
qui se passe dans les hôpitaux et puis
les ce qui se passe en termes de
contamination dans le grand public
pendant la population générale donc pour
l'instant les hôpitaux c'est très tendu
ce n'est pas le débordement que l'on a
connue il ya il ya quelques mois mais
c'est quand même une situation très très
tendue alors est ce que la
décroissance constatée depuis seulement
une semaine il faut être très prudent il
va se répercuter d'ici 15 jours parce
que c'est à peu près le délai d'ici
quinze jours dans les hôpitaux on
l'espère mais rien n'est certain car on
va maintenant assister à la rentrée pas
seulement la rentrée scolaire mais le
retour des vacanciers et ses vacanciers
comme chacun le sait maintenant on est
et on était dans des zones où la
contamination ont été extrêmes
c'est-à-dire les côtes en gros les côtes
les côtes françaises les lieux de
maquettes de de vacances et donc ils
rentrent chez eux tous ces gens là et
qu'est ce qui va se passer en termes de
contamination si nous ne sommes pas
assez vacciner donc ça c'est toute la
question c'est pour ça que je crois
qu'il faut rester très très prudent vous
vous attendez justement après ce retour
de vacances de nouvel arrivé dans l'est
dans les hôpitaux de france
on s'y attend le jeu s'ils attendent eux
voudrait dire qu'on a une certitude et
on ne va pas mais on l'espère en tout
cas on espère qu' il n'y aura pas cette
cette avalanche de caden dans les
hôpitaux maintenant que je ne peux
absolument rien rey après dire parce que
tout dépend
vraiment tout dépend de la vaccination
et de la vaccination des de la
population au sens le plus large du
terme dans l'isère est plutôt très bien
vaccinés donc je pense que la
répercussion dans notre chu
sera moindre et mais dans d'autres dans
d'autres endroits
la situation peut vite devenir
extrêmement préoccupante parlons de
vacciner vaccination qu'il est
aujourd'hui la part de personnes
vaccinées vous recevez au chu de
grenoble est la part de non vaccinés
aussi 90% de non vaccinés
les hospitalisations c'est une épidémie
il y actuellement une épidémie chez non
vaccinés ça c'est très très claires et
en ce qui concerne les
admissions dans les hôpitaux c'est dans
la très immense majorité des cas je vous
disais 90% des personnes qui ne sont pas
vaccinés les 10% restants c'est des
personnes qui sont mal vaccinés soit
parce qu'ils n'ont reçu qu'une seule
dose est là malheureusement on sait
qu'il y a il faut absolument la deuxième
pour être pour être protégé soit des
personnes qui sont particulièrement
fragiles
immunodéprimés et ces personnes là on
s'est effectivement que les soit très
âgées on sait que chez eux c'est les
vaccins marche moins bien mais quel que
soit le vaccin pas spécialement connus
tout autre quel que soit le mc5 donc ça
c'est les 10% qui les lie consentir est
mais 90% ce sont des non vaccinés alors
olivier verrons a aussi voulu rassurer
quant à la composition des vaccins est
ce que vous arrivez toujours à
comprendre
que certains ne soient toujours pas
rassuré
non je le comprends pas je le comprends
pas mais en fait c'est un ressort
intellectuelle
tout à fait tout à fait connu c'est à
dire que je ne veux pas être vaccinés
pour multiples raisons
et surtout idéologique et je construis
des réseaux d un des raisonnements
pseudo scientifiques pour ne pas l'être
c'est ça la démarche il est il est pas
possible
de
continuer à penser que les vaccins sont
dangereux il ya plus que de 4 milliards
de doses qui ont été administrées dans
le monde à ce jour sans qu'ils aient la
moindre le moindre indication de de
gravité significative à la après
l'injection de ces vaccins donc on est
on est vraiment quand on refuse le
vaccin sous prétexte de ne pas avoir
d'informations non c'est qu'on n'a pas
voulu écouter l'information merci
beaucoup jean-paul stade avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes infectiologues au
chu de grenoble merci beaucoup